et puis ce soir pour ce deuxième doit on
veut que qui fait on veut que j'ai super
content mais qu'est ce qui t'arrive
mais hier l'avocat il lui a dit c'est un
super bon mais qu'est ce qui t'arrive
mais c'est notre ami les dans l'émission
enfin un petit changement mais attend à
l'est de l'élu e devrait il pas ce qu'il
a mais qui s'est passé entre vous mais
rien rien vous voulez qu'on repasse
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
voilà il est malheureusement et on a les
sens quand le minibar dans les loges on
ne fera plus l'erreur de maintenant
voilà je vous le dis alban ivanov
j'attends fait sérieux par contre c'est
chiant fait ce qui sera sa lame est
super content
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
entre nous c'est pas bien qu'un débat
ait d'autres jeunes comme à l'habitude
tu vas revenir j'ai dépassé juste voilà
on va là bas on va lui donner une volvic
et puis tout va rentrer dans l'ordre